I hate intros nanatsu no taizai season 1
we kick things up in Leonys with an
older knight and a young squire coming
across dozens of holy Knights who were
killed instantly by only seven people
those seven people came to be known as
the seven deadly sins now we jump ahead
10 years to Cain's village where we are
introduced to the main character Mellie
Otis who is the owner of a bar called
the boar hat with the help of hawk his
Opie talking pig someone in a full suit
of armor mumbling about the seven deadly
sins enters the bar the girl in the army
collapses with her helmet falling off
revealing the Cutie Elizabeth Leonys she
explains that she is looking for the
seven deadly sins
apparently the holy Knights are correct
and the seven deadly sins were trying to
save the kingdom ten years ago she isn't
there long before a group of Knights
come looking for her vaca meliodas buy
her some time until twe go a holy
Knights apprentice attempts to kill them
it's revealed that Elizabeth is actually
a princess of the kingdom but that
doesn't stop - we go from trying to kill
her Billy Otis steps in and one taps the
big boy hurling him through the air
after the pie had concluded he reveals
his true identity to Elizabeth as the
leader of the seven deadly sins he tells
her that he is looking for the other six
sins and invites Elizabeth to join in
Huck's thick mom comes to picks him up
with a war hat in tow and they continue
their search episode two they arrive at
Burnie a village who can't get water
because a holy night named killed
Thunder had blocked the water with his
sword only another holy night has the
strength to remove the sword so the
villagers fail even after banding
together really Otis decides to help
them out and quickly removes the sword
without any problems after hearing about
how his sword was removed guilt Thunder
launches a spear towards the village
millio does consent see coming and sets
up to stop it he then launches the spear
back and nearly kills gil thunder gil
thunder will be chasing them now so they
quickly moved to hide in the forest of
white dreams episode 3 after arriving at
the forest of my dreams they run into
prankster amps that impersonate Hawk and
Elizabeth Millie Otis figures out which
one's a real air break their illusion
the Apes retreat back to the giant that
they were being forced to work for who
turns out to be one of the sins named
Deanna she is overjoyed to be reunited
with her captain that she has the hots
for and wants to join them on their
journey till thunder shows up after
pursuing them and begins to fight with
Mellie owed
Miller Yoda's fakes taking a fatal blow
to get information from Gil Thunder and
finds out the location of King and ban
two of the since episode four Deanna
throws Gil Thunder away so that they
could get back on their quest they head
towards bot stay dungeon where ban is
being held to set him free Wow going
there Mellie Otis falls unconscious from
his injuries so they have to take him to
a doctor a holy night named Felicia gets
wind that they are near so she watches a
wave of acidic bugs to attack them and
the town tierno deals with the bugs and
starts heading to the dungeon alone to
free BAM Ben hears that they're coming
so he breaks from his holding cell and
gets a haircut from one of the holy
Knights apprentices Jericho and in the
last scene a holy night named Cody Jia's
appears in the room where Mellie Otis is
recovering episode by Goethe Diaz tries
to take Melanie Otis a sword but this
waits him up revealing a black marking
on his forehead
gudiya sees how strong he is so he
decides to retreat we're gonna jump add
some filler content over to when Mellie
Otis runs into Deanna both her and
meliodas hear a bell from a holy night
that causes hallucinations and causes
them to fight one another some jeffords
get caught up in the fight but manage to
get to safety with the help of Elisabeth
Ben ended up humiliating Jericho by
taking her armor and then gets into a
fight with a holy night Jude who stabs
him in the last scene II episode 6 wall
Mellie Otis and yet are fighting with
one another the holy night put of aja
attached the two Shepherds with bugs
Elizabeth had vowed to protect them and
sustains injuries from the bugs while
trying to get to the child Shepherd but
the child is actually the holy night
ruin who was causing the hallucinations
with his Bell Elizabeth takes a heavy
shot from ruin but manages to break the
Bell in the process cancelling out
though illusions whip the hallucinations
broken Mellie Otis steps in to fight
with ruin while Deanna takes out
Patricia and they both quickly defeat
the holy Knights back on over to ban
who's revealed to have regenerated
powers and takes out Jude with ease in
order to continue his escape Ben Emilio
does have a really unorthodox reunion
when they play fight until the entire
dungeon collapses allowing them to
escape the episode 7 the gang is now
headed to the capital of the Dead to
look for the next same King we get a
flashback of bad trying to drink from
the Fountain of Youth but a girl named
Elaine keeps stopping him after numerous
attempts to steal the water elaine
finally explains to him that if he
steals the water the forest is gonna die
Ben
in a bad guy so after hearing this he
decides to give up on retrieving the
water
anyways back to the president they
arrive at a village where ban runs into
king who he doesn't even recognize
because King had changed forms after
being reunited with everybody King
leaves without saying anything because
he got flustered from seeing his crush
Deanna they find out that the only way
to get to the capital of the dead is a
priceless memory shared with the
deceased none of them can think of
anything except for ban who remembers
Elaine after thinking about Elaine they
all get teleported to the capital of the
dead and King secretly follows them once
they arrived ban sees what appears to be
Elaine in the distance so he chases
after her with King rushing after him
episode 8 a holy night named giver who
is after the sin stabs herself to get to
the capital of the dead
meanwhile back over to the sins we find
out that Elaine is actually the sister
of King Ben has immortality so King
thinks that ban is the one responsible
for killing his sister in order to drink
from the Fountain of Youth King ven
petrifies ban to counter his immortality
and get revenge for his sister but
Elaine spirit shows up and immediately
reverses the petrification a flashback
shows that band in a kill Elaine he was
actually in love with her don't freak
out it's an Alf couple hundred years old
totally legal he was trying his best to
protect the forest and Elaine from a
demon that was attacking them they were
both fatally wounded by the demon and
Elaine forces him to drink the fountains
water giving him immortality while
sacrificing herself Gita comes across
Mele ODIs and the others and turns out
to be pretty strong messing them up in
their fight even after ban joins in King
is left alone with his sister spirit who
makes the request that he helped ban and
forgive him because he's not a bad guy
this is enough closure for King to
finally let go of his animosity towards
Ben and he joins the fight in the last
scene Yepez Odin High King is no slouch
in a fight and uses his sacred treasure
to take out Gita by himself when they
return to the real world King points out
that the only reason they were
struggling against Geeta is because the
other three sins don't have their
treasures they had all lost their
treasures due to various circumstances
so their new goal is to set out and find
their treasures to help them in future
fights we get introduced to Hendrickson
who is conducting various demon
experiments anyhow
Jericho and we go drink demons blood for
power Jericho turns out to be compatible
with the demons blood however twe go
isn't so he blows up back on over to the
gang who advocated Anna's sacred
treasure but they have to enter a
fighting contest in order to win it
episode 10 the binding festival starts
out with a preliminary round where they
narrow the field down to only eight
contestants after that the remaining
eight go one verse one and a single
elimination bracket for the first round
a mysterious woman named Matrona takes
on a holy night named gudiya moore who
she defeats after the fight my throne
attorney at to be Danna who shrunk down
in size because of a giant mushroom that
her and Elizabeth had come across the
second fight is between a holy night
Houser who defeats the former champion
Tai zu moving right along to the third
match with King going up against the
drunk old man turns out King is actually
useless in a fight without his sacred
treasures so the old drunkard man
handles him and in the last match of the
round of a Mele Otis is going up against
ban he episode 11 during the pipe and
seems like he has the upper hand from
stealing belly Otis's power and speed
but Nellie Otis gets that weird mark on
his forehead again and then blasts been
out of bounds for the semi-final matches
Deanna goes up against Houser who uses
wind to try and knock her out of bounds
but she counters with the body slam
winning her the match filled man came
confront smelly Otis during their match
about betraying the kingdom after Malley
Otis explains that he didn't betray the
kingdom he was actually trying to save
it Kane believes him and forfeits the
match the finals end up being between
meliodas and Deanna guaranteeing that
they'll win her treasure back meanwhile
Geetha and Jericho 2.0 are on the way to
fight them II episodes Wow buta and
Jericho interrupt the finals so King
goes to fight them King makes quick work
of them again but then starts to lose
ground against a new holy night named
Hellgren Elizabeth who was also shocked
by the mushroom returns to her normal
size just before she is found by her
older sister Veronica
Millie Otis steps in to make sure that
Veronica can't take a whiz abit back to
her kingdom
Veronica obviously can't fight through
Mellie Otis so she uses a stone called
goddess amber that traps demonic beings
to capture Mellie Otis instead Elisabeth
flees from her sister but trips a
landmine veronica acts quickly to shield
her from the blast but ends up taking
fatal damage while protecting Elizabeth
after
melih Yoda's breaks from the stone and
is half covered in his mysterious black
markings episode 13
well Leodis uses his dark powers in this
trance-like state to fight against the
holy Knights pilgrim ends up fighting
against smelly otis where he matches his
power and gets the best of him while
also stealing melioidosis sword
well we notice is so protective of the
sword because it's actually one of the
keys to reviving the demon clan deanna
manages to return to her normal size and
also found her sacred treasure allowing
her to fight seriously against halgren
O'Brien is ordered to retreat and he
narrowly makes it out with Geetha and
Jericho in tow once things settle down
we find out that Vans overall goal is to
make contact with the goddesses and
resurrect Elaine episode 14 a new group
of holy Knights called dawn roar are
sent out to deal with an armored giant
that has been sighted we're to get a
quick side sir when Katie goes to visit
her younger brother's eel and then kills
three guys who were picking on him back
over to Mele Otis and the others who
come across dawn war as they're
surrounding the armored giant dawn war
approved to be strong opponents as well
which queues the entrance of the fifth
sin go thir who was travelling with the
armored giant episode 15 to avoid a
three-way fight between the sins armored
giant and dawn roar goat there cuts off
the head of the armored giant to give to
dawn roar since their mission was to
stop the armored giant this appeases
them and they take their leave once
they're gone everybody finds out that
the armored giant is actually a giant
demon over to the boar Hatt Kane shows
up to have a drink not knowing that this
is Mele Otis's bar well there he ends up
talking with Elizabeth and tells her the
story of Liz she was originally
sentenced to death but Mele Oda's saves
her from the sentence and they
eventually become lovers back on over to
the demon who was revealed to be Gita's
father Dale a holy night that was
transformed into a demon and one of
Hendrickson's failed experiments King
gives Elizabeth the sword that Liz had
tried given to Mele owed as years ago
Elizabeth passes the sword on to Mellie
Otis and Mellie Otis uses the swords who
killed the demon the episode 16 we get a
look at Hendrickson who has Mellie
Otis's sword and is planning on using it
to summon the red demon race back at the
boar hat Mellie Otis tries convincing
the others to help him retrieve his
sword but it
immediately shot down however they're
kind of forced to change their minds
once the holy night Vivian shows up out
of nowhere and snatches Elizabeth and
Hawk they have no choice but to go and
try and retrieve the two so Deanna
throws meliodas ban and go through
toward the castle they land on the north
side and fight with holy Knights while
on the south side a new character Arthur
Pendragon arrives with an army II
episode 17 the army is actually an
illusion created by Arthur's companion
to get him a meeting with Hendrickson
Hendrickson leads him inside and they
suddenly get into a fight who Liotta's
ban and go through managed to get past
the armies and continue their search for
Elizabeth back over to the boar hat King
uses his black hound Oslo to teleport
Diana inside the castle when she arrives
she is immediately attacked by guilt
thunder Houser hellbrunn and a great
holy night called Dreyfus Dreyfus is way
too strong and deal serious damage to
her
all of the fighting is going on Gita's
younger brother Zeile is walking through
the street and is nearly crushed by
falling debris
Danna sees the falling debris and jumps
on top of him to protect him saving his
life after seeing this heroic action
both Hauser Ankita decide to fight
against rapist and the other knights to
protect her from being killed episode 18
poser and Geetha team up to launch
everything they have at the Knights but
can't even do damage look we go through
shows up and steps into challenged
rapist by himself jump on over to
Elizabeth and Hawk who come across
Elizabeth's other sister Margaret
because why not add another character at
this point
Vivian shows up to teleport them and
gets freaked out by Hawk so she
teleports the pig away and takes
Elizabeth back to the showdown between
Gotha and Dreyfuss where go thir puts
him in a nightmare and plans to leave
Dreyfuss there permanently but Rafe is
somehow breaks free and stabs go through
go Thor falls unconscious while Dreyfuss
is left reeling after that serious
mental attack and has to retreat with
Gil Thunder leaving help Ram to wrap
things up King comes to fight hail bran
just before he kills Deanna and it's
revealed that Hal Bram used to be King's
best friend yep so 19 we get a flashback
of what happened with King and hell bran
King used to be fairy king Harlequin
charged with protecting the elf forest
as well as the Fountain of Youth his
best friend Hal Broome had been attacked
in the human realm so King is forced to
leave his sister Elena and the forest
he's charged with protecting to go to
his aid he finds all of his elves
slaughtered and the man responsible
aldrick who strikes King causing him to
lose his memories
this is when King meets young Deanna who
he bonds with over many years while
trying to regain his memories he finally
remembers his real identity as a nearby
village that King Indiana were friends
with is attacked his best friend Hal
Bram is responsible for the attack as he
has been hunting humans as a revenge for
them attacking the elves pilgrim had
taken on the form of aldrick to never
forget his hatred for the humans
King is forced to kill halgrim in the
end but is sentenced to a thousand years
in prison after taking responsibility
for not being able to prevent the
attacks knowing he can't return to
Deanna he uses his abilities to make her
forget about him before he goes to serve
his time so she has no recollection that
they knew each other when she was a kid
jump back to the present where King has
two
his old friend hellbrunn for the second
time in order to protect Deana back over
to Arthur and Hendrickson who are still
going at it when Mellie Otis steps in in
the last scene episode 20 kill thunder
who was still a squirting Dreyfuss is
sent to fight with Mellie Otis Arthur is
trying to buy Mellie Otis time by
fighting with Hendrickson but ultimately
loses to him over to Elizabeth who wakes
up to find her father King Bartra which
is kind of pointless he back over to
meliodas who has to fight with guilt
Thunder hendrickson and Vivian at the
same time
Millie Otis manages to release Gill
thunder and Margaret from a monster that
was apparently forcing their compliance
with the holy nights know that guilt
Thunder is free he fights against
hendrickson to avenge the death of his
father and defeats him Vivian is the
only one left to fight now which is when
the next sin Merlin who was travelling
with Arthur reveals herself negating
Vivian spells II episode 21 puck was
actually sent into the tunnels beneath
the kingdom and is found by ban who was
trying to make contact with the
goddesses to revive Elaine ban manages
to talk with the goddesses who agreed to
revive Elaine if he kills Mellie Otis
movie Otis Arthur kill Thunder Merlin
and Margaret make it to where Elizabeth
and her father are Merlin uses her magic
to take Arthur and Bartra back to
Camelot and safety bhendrickson who was
thought to be defeated that makes his
reappearance after drinking demons blood
he triggers all the holy Knights who
drank demons blood to turn into demons
and go on a rampage King goes to fight
with Hendrickson but is intercepted by
Hal Bram who was resurrected by
Hendrickson bhendrickson manages to
injure both Mellie Otis and Gil Thunder
in order to keep them alive
Elizabeth agrees to go with him and act
as a sacrifice and the last couple of
scenes ban and Hawk returned to the
surface where ban attacks melio disturb
revival Lane episode 22 Millie Otis
hanpan fight for a bit but they both
agree to put this on hold until they can
save Elizabeth buck takes Mellie Otis to
where Elizabeth is so that he can try
and save her over to King who was
fighting with Hal Bram who was basically
a mindless zombie now and begging for
death so King kills him for the third
and final time breakfast then goes on to
confront Henderson and plants to stop
him to atone for his sins the two of
them fight but Dreyfuss can't even
damage Hendrik sent through his new
demon regeneration pen
and then goes on to kill Dreyfuss
because he won't give up fighting
what's the sins start to get the city
back under control and save some of the
holy nights from the demons blood they
rushed to help malli Otis everybody
regroups a coroner's Hendrickson to
fight him as the fighting commences
Hendrickson crashes into a cliffside and
as it crumbles the body of the demon
that killed Elaine is revealed which is
how Hendrickson was performing his
experiments he episode 23 band goes into
a rage and smashes Hendrickson into the
ground creating massive crater that ends
in a tunnel when the sins go down to
finish him he is waiting by another
demon body this great demons blood was
never compatible with anybody's body
because up until at that point they were
never strong enough however now that
Hendrickson is fused with the red demons
blood he figures that his body can be
compatible he injects the grey demon
blood into his body taking on his final
boss form
he quickly dismantles the sins and when
they returned to the surface all of the
holy nights had shown enough to stop him
as well he prepares to kill meli otis
with a massive attack but the shows real
MVP Hawk takes the shot instead being
killed by the blast the loss of Hawk
triggers Elizabeth's druid priestess
bullet to be awakened and she counters
Hendrickson's next attacked as well as
healing all of the injured sins and holy
nights so I know we also get a random
shot of Elizabeth's presumed dead sister
that died on the landmine Veronica in
the city very much alive
even though Elizabeth's massive healing
affects the injured it can't resurrect
the dead so Hawk doesn't come back
episode 24 with all of the sins he will
they fight hendrickson at full power
everyone is heading both hendrickson as
well as Mellie Otis with powerful
attacks but really only doing damage to
Mellie Otis this is all part of the plan
though as Molly Otis uses his trump card
that takes all of the powers that had
hit him and combines it into one attack
this ultimately one shots Hendrickson
finally defeating the demon
I guess the writers wanted to have mercy
on the poor viewers as well as retaining
the comedy relief of the show so Hawk
turns out to be part Phoenix or
something I don't know Anna Mitty Hawk
is born from the ashes
leader Merlyn informs Mellie Otis that
she can't find the coffin of eternal
darkness which is used to summon the red
demon race as well as spotting a
mysterious creature flying over the city
Elizabeth disobeys her father's wishes
and runs away with Mellie Otis to help
them find the seventh and final sin
towards the end ban leaves the group to
go see the world and we get a flashback
of Liz's last words to Mellie Otis
before she dies being that they will
meet again and finally in the last scene
after the credits guilt Thunder had
found books with the markings that
showed up on both Mellie Otis and
Hendrix in questioning what was father
trying to do this was a really
complicated show with tons of side
stories so if you guys have any
questions please feel free to throw it
in the comments below but in the
meantime I'm going to be doing the next
season and that'll be in the bottom left
oh never I'm finished with it or you can
check out all the no not to no taizai
recaps in this playlist here you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing I hate more
than intros is outros